mijin espère que c'est vrai, je veux dire
que pour cela semble l'estropié mon frère,
tout le monde était assez enthousiaste pour que
j'entre là-bas avec un peu de fracas Bouchon
dommage Jason Statham est l'un de ces
acteurs qui a toujours gardé son sang-froid et l'a
toujours gardé cohérent
oui Statham quel chat cool c'est assez
génial de le regarder en action là-bas
Kurt a vu l'assassin des forces spéciales britanniques comme
un atout unique qu'aucun
gouvernement n'admettrait jamais utiliser,
donnez-lui simplement une arme à feu qui pourrait
montrer que le sang est du sang et il est parti
sans autre choix que de venger
les noms des personnages de son frère Jason venant après
le reste de l'équipe et il les poursuit
un par un nous sommes
chassés le truc de la famille est une grande chose
la similitude moi venant venger mon
frère et Toretto  est tout au sujet de la famille,
je pense que c'est un grand parallèle pour les deux
personnages que vous n'auriez jamais dû gâcher
avec la famille d'un homme
Je t'ai dit, mon frère, la même chose que
le Biff est pris dans un combat de rue